je suis presque 2000 da par bref cette
émission enregistrée vendredi à montréal
et paris étaient diffusés aujourd'hui il
rejette le blâme sur le président carter
pour tout ce qui est arrivé dans leur
pays
raymond saint-pierre à washington dans
le domaine des communications par
exemple il ya des percées assez
intéressantes à faire
transport à peu près sûr on en est
mais quand c'est loin
emportant terry
la turquie a changé sous tour goûte aux
halles lorsqu'il visite de petites
villes comme neige scheer en plein
centre du pays
il peut se vanter d'avoir en quatre ans
de pouvoir amener l'électricité et le
téléphone dans tous les coins de la
turquie on se réjouit cependant de ce
que l'accord annoncé aujourd'hui à
washington soit le premier où on tente
vraiment de réduire les armements
nucléaires
raymond st-pierre qui vient d'arriver en
poste à paris expose deux problèmes le
gouvernement socialiste voyait défiler
dans les rues de france ou ceux là même
qui l'ont appuyé il ya cinq mois au
moment des dernières élections
législatives
[Musique]
une première explosion à une dizaine de
mètres de la fosse aujourd'hui on lui a
remis le prix gémeaux du meilleur
reporter journaliste vraiment
saint-pierre le téléjournal à
berlin-ouest foule de badauds venez voir
ce qui se passait à check point charlie
quelques minutes après l'annoncé de
l'ouverture de la frontière
racisme refait surface l'extrême droite
s'activent étant d'exploiter
l'inquiétude dans la population y avait
certes un des leaders de ces groupes de
casseurs qui nous ont vus entre intimes
et qui s'en sont pris à un cameraman qui
s'en sont pris à moi qui nous ont pas
battus on se reverra à la prochaine
d'ici là on prend soin de soi cobra
merveilleux ces quelques mots rial ce
soir vous a préparé ce montage de
moments magiques se sont produits au
cours de ces deux années
alors le voici dix ans que ce soit là
que soient leurs marchés où ils sont
trés de paix de 6,6 papillon et ça c'est
des scorpions ici fait quoi et ben non
merci on a suivi des militaires qui
devaient aller patrouiller en bateau
justement pour aller chercher des
citoyens encore isolés dans leur maison
mais n'avait pas de bateau norma taux
est en panne vous essayez de
réquisitionner un bateau entre une scène
absolument loufoque dans le contexte ici
les moyens sont pas encore vraiment en
place pour aider la population ça semble
pas être la priorité visiblement
président vous savez qu'au canada nous
sommes très fiers de notre régime de
soins de santé c'est une question de
centimètres aurait été le véhicule avait
été déplacé un petit peu à gauche repas
à droite puis c'était nous qui patio
[Musique]
à lui
lorsque les trois kamikazes sont entrés
au bataclan ils ont laissé une
automobile de 20
et pour le reste bruxelles restera une
ville en état d' alerte pendant encore
bien des jours poutine jouit encore
d'une horizon popularité dans le reste
du pays
c'est sûr c'est certain j'ai très
marginale à cause du trésor du temple de
plus en plus près de nous et les
militaires nous ordonne de prendre
refuge derrière un char blindé
vous devez réaliser plus tard que tout
n'est pas si rose dans cette partie de
la syrie il veut rester dans son pays
malgré la guerre ici raymond st-pierre
radio-canada dans le village d essaouira
en syrie des mesures qu'on retrouvait
ici en russie au temps du communisme
et si raymond st-pierre radio canada à
moscou du sel il y en a partout
sinon il serait difficile d'imaginer
qu'on se trouve bel et bien sûr ce qui
était le fond d'une mère qui atteignait
jusqu'à 40 mètres de profondeur nous
sommes chez les nénettes un peuple
nomade qui s'est installée s'il ya des
millénaires les gens veulent vendre
portable - ce convoi nous la réalité
pourquoi valentin c'est d'abord ce qu'on
doit faire voisiner portaient des
ceintures au feuilleton marque de rachat
de la sport 4 un show de l'attaqué et si
raymond st-pierre radio canada à moscou
à londres à paris à bruxelles
check point charlie nouvelle orléans
washington edimbourg puis mais pologne
syrie en soin de soi au revoir
[Musique]